hello YouTube just lower simmer friends
this is grunge in here now some of my
subscribers have requested that I should
make a reputa against default well the
thing is when your opponent plays d4 to
make a reputa it's like a full-time job
because you can see by the arrows over
here why it has so many options now the
main moves from the black side is Knight
to f6 or the d5 but against each of them
White has a plenty of choices now the
main move and the most often move played
is c4 but apart from c4 White has a few
very good openings for example white can
play over here Bishop to g5 which is
known as a trump or ski attack also
white can play Bishop to f4 which is
known as the London system white can
play Knight to f3 and e3 which is known
as a Col a system and white can also
play Knight to c3 and Bishop to g5 which
is known as a varus of attack but can
also play a quieter systems like Knight
to f3 g 3 and C 4 which is known as a
Catalan variation and there are plenty
more I haven't included the gambits and
other systems and prepare against each
of the system do you require lots of
time and especially if you want to win
and two novels against the system's then
you need to study the variations and the
subdivisions so all in all in this busy
life if you don't have time to study
against each of the system what I have
done in this video is I'm going to show
you one of my own secret weapon which I
occasionally used specially in quick
games
it turns out very well for me now
let me show you the exact piece layout
of the black so black can start either
with the move c6 or the d6 so let's say
here we start with the move c6 followed
by the d6 Queen goes to the c7 square
and meantime when white plays Knight to
f3 we are going to pin that night with
Bishop to g4 then black can play Knight
to d7 and ePHI now these two moves can
be alternate so in some circumstances
black can play e5 first followed by the
Knight to d7 then the other night goes
to the f6 square and Bishop goes to the
e7 square and meaning time depending on
how wide has responded black can choose
his plan so for example if White has
gone on the King side then if you want
to play a very strong positional game
you can castle on the same side and then
you can throw your queen side pawns up
to the border if the White has castle on
the Queen side if you want to play safe
then this time you can go on the Queen
side and you can look forward for the
central break and in either cases if you
want to play aggressive game then you
can do opposite side castle
and look forward for the opposite flank
attack so you can see it's very
versatile opening now every single
opening has a pros and cons for this
opening you should know before you play
it now the plus side is the black piece
layout are very much fixed that means
you do not need to study opening
theories and you can churn out this
moves very very quickly the second good
merit is you are avoiding all the big
traps and the main trapping lines exist
in regular openings you can strongly
look forward for a equal middle game
where the strong player will win the
downside is you giving white somewhat
space in early stages but nevertheless
you will slowly hit back in the middle
game now as usual I am going to show you
some of my own game which will give you
an idea how you can play for the win and
different positions so before we start
let me show you some of the traps exist
in this opening and the first trap which
I want to show you is happens in the
Trump over ski attack so after white
start with the Moody for respond with
the c6 and it's a nature of Trump or ski
player that
he or she will play Bishop to g5 against
any black opening and here will play a
cunning move which is d6 now as per the
normal theory of the Trump over ski the
normal move over here is III but if your
opponent is going to play III against
this system then this is the last time
he is going to play because this will
simply lose a piece after Queen check
and now you can see this pawn right now
it's stopping this Bishop to come back
and just in the fourth move we can win
the one piece of the white so that is
one trap exist especially in Bishop to
g5 line against our structure White has
to play a very very precise pole even if
he play one careless move then he can
lost the game very very easily so let me
show you one of my quickest win from
this opening my opponent plays d4 and I
played with c6 and he responded with a
classical system by the white key for t6
and Knight c3 Queen c7 9 f3 and please
remember whenever the Knight f3 of
course it's time for the Bishop to g4
Moo he played s3
and I drop my bishop back and then he
played Bishop to c4 now I continue with
normal please development so Knight to
d7 and after Bishop to e3
I played ePHI here he responded with the
g4 attacking my Bishop my Bishop drops
back to the g6 and then he played Queen
to d2 and first it looks very obvious
but in fact this is a disaster move
because after blacks next move which is
Knight to f6 you can see the pressure is
building up on the a pawn now the most
natural move is Bishop to d3 but my
opponent thought that the bishop is
sitting idly on this diagonally so my
opponent decided to move his Queen again
with Queen to d3 to protect that pawn
but this leads to losing a piece can you
find it
yep it's defy please note this right now
a pawn is pin and if the bishop moves
back then black can simply grab the
spawn and that will folk the knight and
the Queen in the game my opponent
capture this pawn but after this
following sequence
you can see black emerge with a clear
piece up and at this point my opponent
resign so that is one of the quick game
which I have won and that highlighted
that your opponent has to play a very
very precise moves now let me show you
so the serious games in this line in one
of my game when I played Bishop to g4 my
opponent responded with this move which
is Bishop to e2 again the normal piece
development from the plan
so line is very natural
and here my opponent grabbed the most
space on in the center so he played d5
and there is no need to panic at this
point so you just need to carry out your
normal piece down open so I played
Knight to f6 and then the usual line
goes like this so he castle Bishop to e7
and now he played h3 and my bishop
drawbacks to the h4 and after some
thinking
my opponent decided here to capture my C
pawn and his idea is to pressurize my
backward points on D and C so next few
moves are very logical so he paid Queen
to d2 planning is very simple Luke owns
to come on the D file where it can
pressurize more to that pawn anyways
I carried out normal piece development
so I first of all plays look to be it
attacking the backward pawn and after he
defended I castle on the Kings side and
after the normal move of the wide which
is rook to d1 I played rook F to the
edge and then he played a for gaining
more space on the Queen side and here I
played Knight to f8 so planning is very
simple I'm just right now waiting for
the right move so I played Myra night
which was not sitting idly on d7 so I
want to reroute that night from f8 to e
6 where it can look forward for the
right moment to jump on either on d4 or
the f5 my opponent played and night to
h2 probably he wants to exchange my
bishop but I simply drop my bishop back
to g6 my two pieces are attacking the
pawn here
my opponent made the first small errand
and he played Bishop to d3
and very naturalist that allow me to
break through in the center with this
move which is to defy more often one
mistake will follow with another one so
here my opponent captured the pole and
normal move is recapturing the pole but
instead of that there is a one stronger
move over here which is Bishop to b4
pending tonight
now the ID law should be Queen goes back
to even and then again defend the night
with Bishop to d2 but my opponent
completely missed my next move and he
thought that he will stop my queen
coming into the picture by playing this
move which is g6 so now you can see
right now my queen cannot have access of
this file but he completely all of this
move which is Queen to e5 and now there
is no way white can defend that night
further three or four moves has been
played like take the bishop I recapture
with the night and after Queen to d3
Bishop captures Knight the game being
last long so this kind of errors can be
occurred if your opponent does not play
carefully and as a strong middle game
player you can look forward for a very
good middle game
so far we were dealing with d4e for now
we are going to see one of my own game
which happens in d4 c4 so here my
opponent responded with c4 and I'm going
through the moves very very quickly you
can see it's our normal piece
development except there is one
exception over here why it hasn't
developed the knight over here in this
kind of scenarios what you are going to
do is you will change your order
slightly so instead of Bishop to g4
right now we are going to wait for one
move so we are going to play Knight to
f6 and hear my opponent played Knight to
f3 and then whenever the knight appears
it's time to pin the knight and again
the usual line continues
I can play a Bishop to e7 but instead of
that I prefer that Bishop has a more
suitable square c5 so I decided to play
Bishop to c5 and my opponent defended
the bishop with Queen to d2 and after
some thinking I decided to castlelong
the simple reason is the group has been
arrived at the open file where it can
look forward for a Discoverer attack to
the Queen and the game goes on like this
so my opponent captured Bishop and
recaptured denied few moves are like
this
and here after some thinking I grabbed
that pawn sometimes people get afraid
that you should not capture the pawn if
you are specially done the opposite side
castle but here I don't see any tactics
for the white so I decided to grab the
free lolly and white responded with of
course rook F to be won and then I
responded with Knight to f4 and here he
played this move which is attacking my
queen
so queen drawbacks to c5 and hear my
opponent played Knight to e4 which is
outright mistake because black can
simply reply with this move which is
Queen to f2 and now you can see the mid
has been threatened the only way to
defend is Bishop to d3 but after a very
simple Queen cross Queen Bishop takes
Queen and rook to d2 black has a
tremendous initiative and in fact I won
the game now before concluding my video
I like to show you the most interesting
game which I have played against the
fritz
12 with the system and to my surprise I
found out that even frits cannot exploit
this opening at least for 15 moves
Morris are like this so Fritz started
with the move d4 and I started with our
normal system
and here he played Knight to c3
nevertheless Queen to c7 and it was a
transposition to the classical opening
of the white and here of course Bishop
to g4 first responded with SV the Bishop
drops back and then he played Bishop to
e2 I played Knight to d7 and here he
played a three now with less it's time
for the e5 and here Bishop e3 then
Knight to f6 and then Fritz played night
to h4 so attacking my Bishop if I wish I
can exchange that Bishop but I decided
to protect my Bishop so I played Bishop
to g6 and here Fritz capture my Bishop
and I captured with the H bomb so at
least that give me somewhat half-open H
file here the usual line continues with
Queen to d2 Bishop to e7 and Fitz castle
on the Kings side please note as I
mentioned in my earlier stage that it's
very important that if you want to play
a positional game then you should throw
your queen side pawn and this is a time
to grab some space on the Queen side so
I played a5 and face responded with rook
F 2 d1 and then I simply castle on the
Kings side and then he played this move
which is who goes back to even and then
I played before so you can see it's a
very easy plant to remember all you need
to do is push this guy's up to the board
Fritz immediately stopped my Queen side
advancement with this move which is
before and then I played this move which
is defy so attacking the center right
now you can see the tension has been
built up in the center
and here France played D cross e file
and after some calculation I have gone
through this sequence so a cross B for
attacking the night so Fritz responded
with a cross B for and then I grabbed
that pawn so night cross E 5 and after
Queen to d4 I put my knight on a
wonderful square which is Knight to c4
which has a merit of attacking that pawn
and here if it's responded with a cross
t4i first of all grab the bishop pair so
nigh cross III and after F cross III I
first of all capture the rook and after
Fritz recaptured I played night cross d4
and after night cross B for C cross D
for Fritz played the first attacking
move after the opening which is route to
a 7 and I simply put my Queen on d6
Bishop to f3 and I played first of all
Bishop to f6 gaining time on the Queen
and after Queen drawbacks with D - I
played d4 and if somehow I can manage to
exchange the species then we have an
opposite color Bishop and that leads to
the draw game and that exactly happened
in the game
so I finally managed to draw the game
but I have to admit that
I have done few take-backs so that is
what obviously called some IT fits so
you can see by playing this way even
frits cannot exploit this opening
immediately I hope you enjoy and learn
this wonderful system against a default
please try out in your game and you'll
slowly and gradually familiar with the
different kind of situation and all I
can say is it's a one kind of
transposition to the middle game where
the stronger player will win the game
please feel free to comment on my video
and I'll meet you soon bye